so I'm going to talk about one of my
areas of research which is and banking
fraud and the technology that's used to
prevent it but also understanding how it
actually happens because unless you
understand that it's not going to be
possible to come up with techniques that
will actually prevent it effectively
probably start by looking at how you the
most common are more sophisticated
frauds happen and that will help us
understand about why the banks designed
the defenses the way that they do and
then we can maybe look a bit more about
how the defenses actually work in a bit
more detail the
a problematic situation for bank
customers is something called the the
man-in-the-browser attack so it's not
very good name
it comes from terminology in banking or
computer security more broadly called
man-in-the-middle and this is where the
adversary is somewhere between the
person who is legitimately doing the
transaction and then the person who's
receiving the transaction so in this
case the bank but the reasons called
man-in-the-browser rather than
man-in-the-middle is it's not like the
adversary's just out on the network
somewhere the adversary has actually put
software onto the victims computer
through malware or however and then that
malware is interfering with what the
person sees if we think about this is
the victims web browser you'd put in the
account number you won't send money to
you put in the amount and then you'd put
in a one-time password
how about used to work is that banks
would send a sheet of paper with lots of
passwords that people taped in no these
people have got mobile phones but they
type in a one thing password this looks
kind of secure but the problem is that
if there is a man in the browser
involved this is not actually the real
banking website this is just a peek
screen that is set up by the malware
what's really happening is that the
criminal is booting in the criminals
account number and a much larger about
and this is a detail that is being sent
to the bank the bank will only accept
the transaction if the one-time password
is correct that's fine because the
customer is going to put in the one-time
password here the malware will receive
it and then the one tank password in
there and then the bank will get the
transaction but the bank will see the
criminals transaction not the one that
the customer actually intended so the
customer is logged on to online banking
and the details that the tape in are or
something like ping they'll just email
where gas bill but actually there could
be transferring 100,000
to the criminals account and because the
transaction is actually coming from the
victims own computer and is coming from
their own web browser
I hope yet a hike web browser from the
bank's perspective that's perfectly
legitimate so this was a big problem for
the banking industry in lots of
countries so the banks in most of Europe
have now moved over to not only having a
one-time password but making that
one-time password
linked to the transaction so it's not
just I think II think who someone is
it's a think eating transaction it's
called transaction authentication from
my experience we've been using these
little devices at home for a long time I
know you've brought a few along yeah
although any place is still using this
straight one-time password and system in
the world
so in general even though America is
quite sophisticated most circumstances
for banking and banking security they're
quite behind so in America is actually
quite unusual to do online banking for
moving money around stop checks are
still being used even though in most of
Europe they're gone and in the UK the
banks are trying to get rid of them so
the in general don't really have any
particularly sophisticated banking
security but in some ways that's
actually better for the customer because
the banking laws in the US are very much
consumer focused so essentially if
anything goes wrong the bank will give
your money back even if the bank
believes that you've acted negligently
you've done something that no one could
reasonably expect it to do they're still
legally obliged to give most of your
money money back and in practice they're
actually give all of your money back the
Europe and the UK does have better
banking technology but when it goes
wrong often the customer actually pays
the cost so one of the other things I've
been doing is talking to regulators and
telling them that when they're looking
at banking technology and when that
banking technology is being used to
shift the cost of fraud to the customer
they should look to see if the
security technology is actually working
properly and whether it's reasonable to
meet customers lie or for fraud when
they don't really have any choice about
how the system works or how it's
designed certainly in Europe the more
simplistic systems are either gone or
they're going to be eliminated because
there's a new European law called the
payment services directive - which
actually mandates the more secure
transaction authentication however it
like most laws doesn't actually see the
technical details about how things are
going to work and that's probably good
because politicians are not very good in
developing technology it just says what
what criteria the system should meet and
so there's a huge diversity across all
of Europe and even within countries has
to have these technologies work and in
terms of cryptography they're all
basically okay they may not use the most
modern of cryptography so for example
banking systems often use there's the
data encryption standard rather than the
more modern AES encryption block cipher
but that's essentially irrelevant for
most purposes where they do vary a lot
is in the way that they work and the way
that people interact with them and that
actually causes a huge difference in
terms of their security because if
someone is confused about how they work
then they could be quite easily tricked
into doing something wrong and we've
seen that criminals actually are doing
that so one traditional trick by
criminals is assuming the technology
works what they will see is they'll take
over your web browser and they know tell
you some story and story normally goes
along the lines off there's been some
error money has appeared in your account
and your account is going to be locked
until you send this money back to the
legitimate order and if you log on to
your online banking and look at your
statement then this fake transaction
will be there your balance will be far
larger than it normally will be and
there will be instructions about
transferring this money back to the
right person but actually that's all
fake the money has not appeared in your
account
and the so-called legitimate owner of
the money is actually the criminals
accountant so you use one of these
devices to authorize a transaction to
move this money but actually you're
sending your own money to the criminals
and it could be a long time before you
notice that this has been going on and
that sort of scam works because people
were too distracted by trying to make
the technology work in any way
whatsoever that they don't actually have
the time to think about whether they
really should be using this technology
to do that transaction so essentially
the more obvious and the easier you make
the technology the less likely is that
criminals are going to be able to get
people to act and in secure ways it
seems to me that's kind of a phishing
attack mixed with Mal water so what's
going on with the devices themselves why
have they had to resort to that yeah so
there's three broad categories so
there's the devices that you put your
card into it like this one these are
very common in the UK this isn't a UK
device this is from the Netherlands it's
got a keypads it's got a few buttons and
it got like hard that goes into it
really the device is not doing very much
in this case all the work is actually
being done by the card and that's why
people can actually use someone else's
device in the UK even a device from a
different bank and it will still work
provided they're using their card but
because it's using a card it's got some
limitations so the first one is going to
be actually quite big and chunky because
it's got to be large enough to have
batteries that parish the card and it's
got to be large enough to physically
have the card inside it and that's one
reason they're unpopular so the
alternative is device like this so this
is still got a keypad it's much smaller
much thinner smaller batteries and it
can do that because there's no card at
least be put into it some customers like
this but the downside is that this
device is no linked to you so this is
the one that's linked to your account so
it's not like you can borrow more
someone else's device it's not like you
can have
one device home and when the vase of
work let you can with the card reader
devices like these but with both of
these devices there's got to be some way
for linking the password that it
generates to the transaction details and
the way that this works is you type in
something like either the account number
you're sending the money to or the last
four digits of the account
you're sending the money to and that's a
bit I mean inconvenient particularly if
you have to do it a lot so that's why
there's other devices this has a little
camera on the back you use that camera
to scan a 2d barcode that the bank shows
you and that's much much easier for
customers to use and it means that
you're not just authorizing the last
four digits of the account number the
bank can actually send a lot more
details about the transaction so firstly
that reduces the amount of effort the
customer needs to go to because they
just scanned something rather and type
something and also it gives them more
details which hopefully gives them a
better chance at trying to spot whether
there's one of these scams at work then
we've got yet another one this one also
has a pin with all these devices you
want to check firstly whether the
transaction has been authorized but also
whether the right customer is doing the
transaction and the traditional way to
do that is two factors so something the
customer has and something they know so
for the card reader devices like this
one it's do they actually have the card
and do they know the pin it's a four
digit PIN this is got a four digit PIN
as well this you can have a pin this one
doesn't but the way that the banks use
that is that they ask the customer to
enter a password into the website but
the password has got to be much longer
than a four digit PIN because when
you're typing a password into a website
a criminal can tried lots and lots and
lots of passwords but with all of these
devices where you type a pin into it the
device itself actually checks that the
pin has not been entered too many times
so in the case of the card reader card
has got a
your counter on it and then once that
goes about three the card locks out and
it's similar with these two devices once
the pen has been entered too many times
and these devices they lock and you got
to talk to the bank to unlock them again
the topic botnet was the first one or
one of the first at least introducing
the domain generation algorithms in
order to find the domain where they
would have found a command control
server in a dynamic away during the
infection but what has been done by
researchers in 2009